[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
mathilde de panneaux bonjour beaucoup
d'être avec nous et put et la france
insoumises du val de marne vice
président du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par pascal janin
les bras bonjour pascal et on commence
avec cette interview d'emmanuel macro
qui renoue donc avec la tradition du 14
juillet en lui qui n'avait pas parlé un
14 juillet depuis son arrivée à l'elysée
c'est bien pour vous qu'il renoue avec
cette tradition
non pas particulièrement pour pourquoi
je m'explique ça fait quand même
plusieurs prises de paroles que fait
emmanuel macron on nous annonce des
grands changements et je crois que la
parole du président de la république est
quand même largement démonétisé je
crains qu'encore une fois nous ayons une
prise de parole
grandiloquente du président de la
république mais qui n'annonce aucun
changement forte pour le pays
et quand même j'espère jeu là je vais
être un petit peu méchante mais j'espère
que le premier ministre sera devant la
télévision en train de prendre des notes
pour savoir ce qu'il pourra dire le
lendemain lorsqu'il fera enfin son
discours de politique générale
parce que quand même stéphane peule a
souligné mais c'est la réalité
on se retrouve avec une
hyperprésidentialisation du pouvoir déjà
que la vème république sur le monarque
républicain c'est quelque chose mais
alors là on concentre encore plus les
pouvoirs autour du président de la
république parce que personne ne croit
que monsieur castex va diriger l'action
gouvernementale il va simplement
appliqué ce que va dire le président de
la république et dans ce qui a déjà été
annoncé ça ressemble quand même fuseau
furieusement au monde d'avant voir au
monde d'avant-hier et on ne peut être
même en encore pire que ce qu'il y avait
avant cette crise sanitaire on va
revenir sur le discours de politique
générale mais sur la méthode pour vous
c'est un problème que jean castex n'ai
pas pu faire son discours de politique
générale avant c'est un problème pour le
parlement aussi oui on sait on s'est
retrouvé à faire des questions au
gouvernement avec aucune idée de quel
était le projet politique de ces gens
devant nous on avait une idée grâce à
l'interview d'emmanuel macron la veille
de la nomination
de monsieur castex mais c'est quand même
un problème d'avoir un premier ministre
qui acceptent de ne pas parler avant que
le président daigne parlé et je crois
que on a depuis le début du mandat d'
emmanuel macron un affaiblissement du
parlement et que cet affaiblissement du
parlement se continue et je crois que
c'est extrêmement néfaste pour la
démocratie
le président va parler de relance
comment voyez vous cette relance
à droite on l'appelle accéléré vous
paraître leur planification peut-être en
commissariat au plan
expliquez-nous qu'elle renonce il doit
faire alors justement cette semaine nous
allons faire une proposition d'un plan
de ce que nous appelons à une
planification du déconfinement
économique
donc parce que nous ne sommes pas pour
relancer pour relancer lorsque j'entends
le président dire que l'horizon d'avenir
qu'il propose aux français et aux
françaises c'est de travailler plus pour
produire plus je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ça d'autant plus que quand même on
a un gouvernement qui refuse d'assumer
son rôle d'état pourquoi refuse-t-il
d'assumer son rôle d'état on est en
train de distribuer de l'argent public
de l'argent des français et des
françaises à des grandes entreprises qui
licencient à tout va c'est à dire qu'on
utilise de l'argent public pour
licencier et pour continuer à
délocaliser
je pense dans les plans de licenciements
évidemment à sanofi mais aussi arnaud à
air france à nokia et il y en a beaucoup
d'autres
comment est ce possible qu'un
gouvernement qui remet de l'argent
public c'est pas un problème de remettre
de l'argent public mais qui remet de
l'argent public ne met aucune condition
ni sociale ni écologique à cette relance
est justement la période du coronavirus
aurait dû être un moment où au moment où
tous arrêtés où on aurait pu re
réfléchir aux activités essentielles à
celles qui répondent aux besoins
essentiels de la population et opérer
ainsi une bifurcation écologique et
solidaire dont nous avons impérativement
besoin au vu de l'enjeu du 21e siècle
c'est à dire l'urgence écologique et il
ya beaucoup de choses à faire dans ce
plan de déconfinement vous verrez les
propositions qu'on fait je vais pas été
déjà le mot plan de développement
économique pour une biture qu'elles
furent coaching traduisent concrètement
ça veut dire quoi
dix formations je pense que les gens
comprennent assez simplement c'est à
dire vous êtes sur une route et cette
route nous amène quand même vers un
désastre
il faut faire bifurquer il faut changer
notre modèle parce que sinon on arrive
devant
monde qu'est ce qu'on fait on ferme les
centrales nucléaires on interdit les
avions qu'est ce qu'on fait sur
l'enrichissement la planification c'est
ce qui permet déjà déjà c'est ce qui
permet de ne pas laisser le marché
décider seul de ce qui doit être fait
parce que ça on a vu les résultats que
ça entraîné et je pourrais en revenir
dessus si beau si vous le souhaitez et
la deuxième des choses c'est la garantie
justement de pouvoir démocratiquement
décider de quel système économique nous
voulons sur la planification qu'est ce
qui est à faire par exemple vous parler
du nucléaire c'est un très bon exemple
c'est un exemple de planification le
nucléaire je suis une anti nucléaires et
pourtant c'est un moment l'état a dit ok
nous allons investir dans le nucléaire
nous allons former des gens nous allons
investir de l'argent nous allons faire
un blanc de développement du nucléaire
donc si on l'a fait sur le nucléaire on
peut le faire sur beaucoup d'autres
choses et je crois qu'on peut le faire
pour aller vers le 100% énergies
renouvelables on peut le faire pour
aller vers la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments dont nous parlons depuis je ne
sais pas combien de temps et qui n'est
toujours pas à la hauteur des actes dont
donc qu'il faudrait mettre en place on
est recalé le gouvernement s'attelle à
vendre et c'est la rénovation thermique
malheureusement toutes les associations
le 10 à un niveau qui est largement en
ayant mis le logement sous la tutelle du
ministère de l'écologie pour vous
aimeriez bon signal en tout cas à un
niveau qui est qui est très faible et
sur le sur le périmètre du ministère de
l'écologie on pourra en parler parce que
je crois que là encore le ministère de
l'écologie se fait encore plus affaiblir
dans ce remaniement est mal logés on
pourra y revenir si vous si vous le
souhaitez donc donc on pourrait faire ça
on pourrait par exemple sortir des
pesticides et du glyphosate dont on nous
avait promis qu'on en sortir en 2021 et
puis finalement ça sera 2027 au moins et
créer des emplois dans une agriculture
paysanne et écologique
on pourrait créer des emplois planifié
pour faire en sorte qu'on ait enfin des
métiers du soin et des métiers du lien
qui soit à la hauteur de la situation
je parle pour les personnes en situation
de handicap pour les personnes âgées
bref on a beaucoup de chantiers à faire
dans notre pays on a beaucoup de choses
à faire mais il faut une volonté
politique de le faire il faut une
organisation c'est une méthode la
planificateurs du coup si c'est juste
les grandes entreprises le jeu pousser
des ailes macron qu'un créant au
commissariat au plan comme on l'entend
pour vous ce serait une bonne chose là
vous applaudirez en tout cas bon alors
on ne sait pas s'il va vraiment le faire
mais en tout cas c'est c
évident que c'est une victoire
culturelle pour nous c'est une victoire
culturelle parce que on était les seuls
à parler planification que ça fait quand
même longtemps qu on dit que c'est la
méthode qu'il faut mettre en place donc
donc oui c'est une victoire culturelle
après la question c'est que quand ils
ont quand même beaucoup à apprendre
parce que je rappelle que ce
gouvernement en termes de laisser faire
du marché et quand même le champion
c'est pas le champion de la terre c'est
le champion des transnationales les
traités de libre échange qu'ils ont mis
en place le ceta le vietnam d'ailleurs
sur la parole du président vous avez vu
par exemple ce qu'il a dit devant la
convention citoyenne pour le climat le
mercosur donc avec le traité de libre
échange avec le mercosur
rappelez-vous les flammes alors j bolzan
araud a le feront pas celui-là il a dit
qu'il ne signerait pas bah oui mais le
problème c'est que il dit il dit je ne
le signe pas parce que molson or on a
menti le protège pas l'asile amazonie je
vois pas mal son arbre n'a pas changé
d'attitude entre temps et alors il dit
qu'il ne le signaient pas or les
négociations sont en train d'aboutir
elles vont aboutir cet automne donc moi
j'aimerais savoir si ce gouvernement
s'engage vraiment sur cette parole du
président ou si c'est de nouveau une
parole du président sur lequel on peut
passer comme ça et de nouveau à une
sorte de mensonges qui est fait aux
français aux france j'espère qu'on va
s'y opposer je serai la première à dire
que c'est très bien si ce traité ne se
fait pas mais ce gouvernement était
champion de tout ça les traités de libre
échange
le service public ferroviaire qui a été
complètement détruit pour ouvrir à la
concurrence et je ne sais quoi je ne
sais quoi donc ils ont beaucoup à
apprendre pour faire de la planification
mais bon on sera là pour leur donner des
conseils leur proposer notre plan et
nous en avons fait c'est pour vous pour
rien ça va s et si bien qu ayant haut
commissaire au plan vous lui tendez la
main vous dites on travaille ensemble on
a on n'a pas besoin d'autres nous nous
sommes l'opposition c'est ce que barbara
pamphili la nouvelle ministre de
l'écologie mal dit quand je lui posais
des questions sur ce qu'elle allait
réellement faire sur cette question
s'ils avaient un haut commissariat au
plan
elle me dit nous allons travailler
ensemble on est on est pas en nous nous
sommes l'opposition à ce gouvernement
nous sommes nous sommes une opposition
par contre des propositions nous en
faisons tout le temps c'est à dire que
le plan de déconfinement c'est quand
même le cinquième plan que nous
proposons depuis le début du cours aux
navires us on en a fait sur beaucoup de
sujets différents
on apprend on a fait douze propositions
de loi juste pendant la période du
confinement
on a fait plusieurs guides donc bon
ils peuvent piocher nos idées sont
libres dedans parce que je crois
qu'elles sont bonnes pour l'intérêt
général veut dire clairement quand vous
dites vous êtes l'opposition ça veut
dire vous pouvez reprendre nos
propositions et on travaillera pas
ensemble c'est ça ça veut dire que ce
que je voulais dire par ils ont beaucoup
à apprendre sur la planification parce
qu'ils ont laissé faire à tout va ça
veut dire que eux mêmes doivent rompre
avec leur propre politique et revenir
sur des choses qui l'ont fait
s'ils veulent être crédibles sur cette
question de la planification françois
bayrou ce sera un bon haut commissaire
au plan pour vous je ne sais pas la
question en fait la question n'est pas
celle des personnes mais la question est
celle des politiques
et là encore je crois que vient beaucoup
à faire sur le ministère de l'écologie
vous parliez du périmètre pour vous
c'est quoi il ya un problème avec ce
périmètre
bien sûr quand vous regardez les
secteurs les plus polluants
vous avez mon certes le transport qui
est dedans mais vous avez quand même
celle qui est à enlever 12% des
effectifs des agents du ministère de la
transition écologique avec d'ailleurs un
mouvement fort deux de ses agents la qui
a été remerciée ministre du travail ce
qui est quand même un comble pour
quelqu'un qui a dépassé notre capacité à
la dz d'experts si ce public
et puis par exemple vous n'avez toujours
pas l'agriculture dans le commissaire de
l'homélie
vous avez quand même noté peut-être que
c'était ministère de la transition
écologique et solidaire le solidaire
vient de disparaître ce qui est quand
même un signal assez mauvais je crois
sur sur l'ampleur et justement la
cohérence du projet global qui devait
porter un ministère de la transition
écologique et solidaire
bon vous avez quand même un barbare à
pompe il y arrive à un ministère qui n'a
pas tous les tenants et les aboutissants
pour pour pour mener une politique
réellement écologie si tenté qu'il y ait
une volonté politique
avant nous les confiner il faut aussi
éviter de reconfirmer vous est favorable
au port du masque obligatoire dans les
lieux qui accueillent du public et à
l'interdiction de rassemblements comme
ce qu'on a vu à nice ou dans les deux
sèvres ce week-end alors alors sur sur
la question d'une seconde vague non nous
avions alerté assez tôt sur cette
question-là d'être extrêmement prudent
oui nous sommes favorables au port du
masque dans des locaux mais à une
condition quand même qui est une
condition extrêmement importante et que
nous demandons depuis maintenant
d - qui est la question de la gratuité
des masques parce que on ne peut pas
avoir à continuer dans une situation où
60 millions de consommateurs avait
estimé que c'était entre 150 euros et
200 euros par famille pour pour avoir
des masques donc si les masses ne sont
pas gratuits ils ne seront pas portés
par tout le monde dans tous les cas donc
si cette question de la gratuité des
masques et est posée oui nous y sommes
favorables mais comme justement la clé
en main pour être clair mat il pas
nourri favorable ça veut dire qu'il faut
le rendre obligatoire ou pas oui donc
pouvoir pour l'obligation est d'ailleurs
moi je tiens je je nous avons plusieurs
fois pointé notamment dans la commission
d' enquête citoyenne que nous avons mené
pendant le confinement nous avions
interrogé des soignants des experts des
professionnels des caissiers des bons on
avait pointé plusieurs fois que le
discours gouvernemental sur cette
question là de dire vous vous rappelez
de madame ndiaye il faut avoir fait
polytechnique pratiquement pour porter
un masque le mas ne sert à rien et
quelque chose qui a énormément porter à
confusion mais je sais pas si sûr ça que
je voulais insister c'est que au delà du
port obligatoire du masque parce que
c'est bien aussi de poser les problèmes
sur des choses mais faut pas trop
individualiser les problèmes quand même
oui il y à une question autour du port
du masque oui il ya une question autour
de la gratuité des masses mais quand
même si on a une seconde vague vague
qu'est ce qui a changé dans le système
de santé pour pouvoir faire face à ça
les syndicats ont signé le ségur
oui non mais d'accord ils ont aussi ils
vont signer il faut signer à milly paix
sauf de la section danse très fermé des
lits dans notre pays aujourd'hui
vous avez vu des réouvertures de livres
vous avez vu des embauches de soignants
vous avez vu on n'a pas tous a dit on
n'est pas prêt comprenez quand même nous
on a fait on a fait 7 7 7 commission
denquête c'était à la fois pour on a
fait des propositions dans cette
commission denquête qui on a fait quand
même 150 dition donc ça nous a permis de
faire plusieurs propositions mais aussi
bon d'enquêter sur les responsabilités
de la situation comment est ce possible
que le sixième pays le plus riche au
monde arrive autant affaiblie de vin
devant une crise sanitaire telle que
celle ci comment est ce possible que on
n'est pas une gestion de crise mais une
gestion de pénurie de pénurie de
soignants de pénurie de lits de perrine
urines masse de pénurie tests etc etc et
bien les conditions n'ont pas été mises
en place pour changer cela et d'ailleurs
quand vous regardez on va arriver
peut-être remaniement mais quand vous
regardez je sais pas c'est de
l'aveuglément idéologique et qui est-ce
qui met en premier ministre celui qui
était dans le cabinet xavier bertrand
qui a supprimé des milliers de lits et
qui a installé la tarification à l'acte
et pareil pour madame bachelot qui elle
aussi a participé à faire de l'hôpital
de faire fonctionner un hôpital comme
une entreprise privée et on croit qu'on
va convainc qu'on va vraiment changer
tout ça là dessus alors moi je n'y crois
absolument pas rascal le rappeler il ya
quand même aussi négocié qui va être
signé
si on signé cet après midi avec un
discours d'ailleurs de jean castex il ya
183 euros d'augmentation nets mensuels
pour les pour les soignants du public
des ehpad ya 15000 postes qui vont être
créés l'un de 8 mille créations de
postes mais bon il y aura quinze mille
postes en plus est ce que pour vous
c'est pas quand même un bon signal même
les syndicats parlent d' accord
historique
c'est le minimum après ce qui s'est
passé c'est à dire que c'est à dire que
celles et ceux qui ont été en première
ligne quand même risqué leur vie sur
cette question là et qui sont celles et
ceux qui nous ont permis de tenir face à
cette crise parce que c'est grâce à
l'engagement de ces femmes et ces hommes
qu'on a réussi à tenir
donc c'est quand même le minimum d'avoir
une augmentation de salaire dans un pays
quand même où on est tout en bas des
classements sur un certain nombre
d'emplois et je pense notamment aux
infirmières mais pas que don donc c'est
bon il demandé 300 euros on n'y est pas
et même avec trois cents euros je crois
que en termes de classement on n'y était
pas non plus nous on disait dans qu'il y
avait c'était à peu près 500 euros de
différence à peu près avec la moyenne de
l'oscd mais bon passons là dessus donc
oui une petite augmentation qui est
qu'ils aient fait bon c'est le minimum
il ya des embauches mais le le de
l'autre côté et ça ça continue vous avez
un hôpital près de bordeaux qui entraîne
fermé vous avez dans ma vie vous avez
des délits qui ferment de séjour de
longue durée
ça ça veut dire qu'on ont continué à
réduire l'offre de soins donc moi pour
moi c'est un problème parce que sur
cette question là où tout le monde s'est
rendu compte de l'importance d'avoir un
service public fort sur cette question
d'avoir une sécurité sanitaire une
souveraineté sanitaires rendez vous
compte luxe cher les derniers à
fabriquer des bouteilles d'oxygène
médicales qui sont indispensables pour
le transport notamment
deux malades ont on les laisse on laisse
ses compétences la mourir c'est à dire
qu'on laisse un actionnaire faire comme
il veut avec son jouet le cas s'est
cassé ses compétences là donc nous n'y
sommes pas sur ces questions là sur la
question de la souveraineté cinqueterre
nous n'y sommes pas sur la question de
d'augmenter les les offres de soins
nous n'y sommes pas allés à ceux des
syndicats de soignants vous l'auriez
signé vous cet accord est ce que cet
après midi à matignon nous ce n'est
qu'il y aurait votre signature
bah moi je ne suis pas syndicaliste mais
après les syndics et les syndicats
j'imagine aussi on cet esprit de dire on
prend on prend tout ce qu'on peut
récupérer ça veut pas dire que derrière
il y aura pas des revendications qui
vont continuer et elles sont légitimes
parce qu'il faut toujours se rappeler
parce que ça on a un peu tendance à
l'oublier que la crise du coronavirus
elle arrive quand même
après un an de grève du personnel
soignant et notamment des urgences qui
réclamaient ces augmentations de
salaires etc augmentation de moyens
humains et matériels
allez on va parler des municipales une
question d'abord sur le tribunal
administratif de nantes qui a annulé la
semaine dernière l'élection municipale
dans une commune de loire-atlantique
malville et cimente la crise sanitaire à
dissuader les électeurs de venir et que
du coup l'abstention a été forte qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette décision
c'est une décision qui cogère j'avoue je
n'avais pas vu mais qui est qui est
assez intéressante parce que il ya une
vraie question à se poser autour du
maintien de ces élections municipales
moi je viens d'une circonscription par
exemple vous avez la ville en france où
il ya eu le plus fort taux d'abstention
c'est à dire 77 % des gens qui ne se
sont pas déplacés pour choisir ce qui va
se passer dans leur ville sur les six
prochaines années et ça pose un vrai
problème démocratique
ça pose un vrai problème démocratique
d'avoir une abstention qui est
historiquement forte sur une sur une
élection comme les municipales qui
d'habitude sont désolés que je vous
expliquais uniquement par la crise
sanitaire en os que là on est en train
de mettre le doigt dans un engrenage
bandits compliqué en tuteur en tout cas
je pense que plutôt qu'une décision
juridique judiciaire sur ces questions
là moi je pense que nous nous sommes
partisans depuis longtemps de la
constituante de remettre à plat les
règles du jeu je pense que c'est là
dessus qu'il faut agir parce que là où
vous avez raison c'est que c'est vrai ce
n'est pas uniquement liée à la crise
sanitaire
il ya un dégoût de la politique qui a
été créée il ya on a écarté un nombre de
gens de la politique et ses salles à la
question fondamentale qu'il faut qu'il
faut se poser mais en tout cas moi je
vous dis à la france insoumise nous ne
satisferont jamais d'une démocratie où
les la moitié ou les trois quarts du
peuple sont absents alors les choix oui
donc votre consoeur député clémentine
autain lundi on s'est plantés de
stratégie on a raté six municipal jean
luc mélenchon a mis en échec
comment vous l'expliquez et comptez-vous
rebondir sur les régionales l'année
prochaine alors effectivement jean luc
mélenchon lui même l'a dit on en a subi
un échec après la la on dit c'est nous
on a on a essayé quelque chose que nous
devions faire c'est à dire on a essayé
de faire des listes citoyenne qui
justement ramène la mobilisation
populaire sur voilà à la politique
comment est ce que on refait on redonne
les clés de la ville aux citoyens et aux
citoyennes notamment avec bon dans
beaucoup de villes où on était présent
dès proposition de référendum
d'initiative locale et beaucoup d'autres
propositions sur des questions
démocratiques et de participation
citoyenne
bon quand vous êtes dans des élections
vous avez 50 60 70 80 % d'abstention
c'est à dire que la mobilisation
populaire forcément d'avoir des délices
citoyenne avec le pari de la
mobilisation populaire ça ne fonctionne
pas vous comprenez bien que si les
jambes ne ne vote pas de manière forte
forcément ça ne fonctionne pas d'où les
d'où l'échec effectivement que nous que
nous avons suivi mais ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ne fallait pas faire cette
stratégie je crois que c'était important
de le faire et qui compris c'est notre
rôle
rappelez-vous en 2016 ce sel et le
mouvement politique qui a été recherché
celles et ceux qui n'étaient pas
inscrits sur les listes électorales et
trois millions de gens non inscrit les
six millions et demi de gens mal
inscrits c'est la france insoumise qu'il
a fait parce que nous n'acceptons pas
que tout le monde ne puisse pas aller
voter
une fois ça dit il ya quand même quelque
chose c'est que dans beaucoup d'endroits
où il y a eu une félicitation de vague
verte etc
rien n'aurait été possible sans la les
insoumis alors on va parler de grenoble
on va parler oui on peut parler de balle
et on peut parler de bordeaux où le fait
qu'ils aient qui est pas les insoumis
fait gagner le maire de toulouse où le
fait que vous étiez avec eux vous n'avez
pas gagné donc c'est un peu contrastée
oui non mais c'est certain mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que non dans beaucoup
des défunts beaucoup dans non pas mal
des grandes villes il ya aussi cette
participation des insoumis a permis
aussi à des listes de gagner mais voilà
mais je crois que moi j'assume que cette
stratégie justement d'avoir fait des
listes citoyenne et de ramener les gens
à la politique en disant nous devons
faire la politique avec les gens et
passants les gens extrêmement les
dernières questions vu l'échec que vous
reconnaissez que jean luc mélenchon
reconnaissent que ce sera la même
stratégie régionale ou étrangers en
plein
fratelli sommes en train et d'ailleurs
c'était noté dans l'interview de jean
avec mélenchon nous sommes en train
d'aller voir différents partenaires
notamment le parti communiste avec qui
nous avons fait quand même deux
élections présidentielles déjà déjà
passé nous sommes en train d'aller voir
les différents partenaires et de
réfléchir en tout cas différents
partenaires si c'est toujours un peu
tout le monde du npa du centre gauche
the three ou non n'a pas encore on n'a
pas été voir le ps et vous n'irez pas
les voir non je ne pense pas enfin
peut-être peut-être qu'il y aura des
alliances à des endroits avec le centre
gauche ps ee lv je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas en tout cas ce que je veux dire
c'est que la question de ce que nous
portons en politique n'est pas juste une
question d'alliance deux parties c'est
une question de programme et ce sur quoi
nous assistons c'est la question de la
clarté
parce que je crois que nous avons besoin
de ça en politique qu'en tant de
promesses ont été bafoués et merci
beaucoup merci s'est-il panneaux d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin merci pascal si
on passe tout au club des territoires